der Januar war ziemlich wild und wir
haben wirklich einiges erlebt und wenn
ich einiges meine dann meine ich auch
wirklich einiges es ist nicht immer
alles glatt gelaufen aber es war
lustiger Monat wir zeigen euch jetzt mal
was alles geschehen ist
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
herzlich willkommen im neuen Jahr heute
geht's endlich mal wieder eine einfache
Torte ein klapsandwich Spaghetti Auflauf
Ferrero Rocher Cookies eine 15 Minuten
noch die Pfanne knuspriges Sesam
Hähnchen ihre 12 Geburtstagstorte
perfekt
reicht für heute weiter geht's mit
backen
[Musik]
seid ihr auch fleißig und Essen ich auch
okay also man hätte auch eine größere
Schüssel nehmen können aber nicht müssen
wer kann der kann
man den größeren Tropfen bitte sei nicht
so klein
Zettel
wo steht heiße Tänze ach so tik tok
Tänze ach so wir können aber auch heiße
Tänze machen bitte nicht nein nein nein
gemeinsam sind Tango
so nein herzlich willkommen
im neuen Jahr
ready
ja moin
Video machen als Torte also ein Rezept
als Rap video
Punkte
guten Morgen Sonnenschein nein du
brauchst nicht traurig sein Muffin geht
wieder abgehen
kurz durchgedreht und schmeißt Kartons
um aber ist okay denn viel Feedback kam
mein Laptop habe ich noch an hoppala das
waren die Weihnachtsferien ich sag's
euch ich habe einfach vergessen oh ich
hätte
kommen könnte und dann einfach so eine
Torte
bewertet Sally 3 darf ich das Mikrofon
weiterhin benutzen nein
was hast du gerade gegen meinen Sellerie
gesagt was hast du gesagt hör auf damit
hör auf damit die Menschen zu verwöhnen
lecker
[Musik]
beim Reis allein schon hat Salz gefehlt
vom 13
jetzt was auf der Optik nein zum Glück
habe ich nicht auf die Kamera gespritzt
so Konversation führen sie auch in
anderen Filmgenre
wenn
du diese Baumscheiben zum Präsentieren
wo sind die denn magst du einen holen
diese Holzbretter
[Musik]
hat auch ein bisschen Mayonnaise gemacht
da ist und wenn auch das Brot nur Butter
drauf macht
[Applaus]
und dann sind sie nach dem Backen
wirklich rundherum wunderschön
hoffentlich hoffentlich
denkst du das sind 20 cm
Absetzen von
genau ich zeig mal kurz die Zutaten
[Musik]